el objetivo del gobierno con esta nueva
ley es frenar la inmigración ilegal a
través del Canal de la Mancha que en
2022 alcanzó récords con más de 45.000
personas que llegaron a través de esta
vía con esta nueva ley quienes lleguen
al Reino Unido por el Canal de la Mancha
o por otras vías serán inicialmente
detenidos luego enviados deportados
expulsados a terceros países Incluso si
los países de esas personas son seguros
puede ser reenviados a sus países de
origen y no podrán volver a intentar si
quiera solicitar el asilo en este país
están exentos inicialmente los menores
de 18 años y quienes tengan condiciones
médicas de salud graves el Primer
Ministro Richie sunac explicó esta tarde
que hará todo lo posible todo lo que
esté en su poder para acabar con las
bandas criminales que están detrás de
esta inmigración ilegal y que
prácticamente todos los días ponen en
riesgo la de miles de personas que
tratan de llegar a este país en pequeñas
embarcaciones y Sabiendo lo que se viene
la batalla jurídica dijo estar listo
para darla porque sabe las implicaciones
en el tema de Derechos Humanos que esto
tiene y el gobierno británico espera
también que el gobierno francés coopere
más en este asunto y será uno de los
temas esenciales de la Cumbre entre
Richie sunaki Manuel macron en París el
próximo viernes de otro lado el partido
laborista en oposición dijo que esta ley
no resuelve de fondo el asunto y que por
el contrario va a Seguir generando más
colapso en un sistema que ya está roto